في هذه الاثناء قال يوري مديار قائد
اللواء الميكانيكي 28 بالجيش الاوكراني
قال ان وحدته الاستطلاعيه تلقت امرا
بالانسحاب من مدينه باخموت شرقي اوكرانيا
واكد ما ديار انه سينفذ الاوامر رغم عدم
معرفته لاسباب هذا القرار
اكثر من الوضع في الشرق تحديدا الوضع في
بخموت عامر
نعم ازدهار يعني لا السياسيين ولا
العسكريين الاوكرانيين ومنذ فتره ينفون او
ينكرون بان الوضع خطير ومعقد ومتوتر داخل
مدينه محمود لكنهم في نفس الوقت وما زالوا
الى الان يؤكدون ان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه لن تنسحب من هذه المدينه وهي
متمسكه فيها بل انه تذكرين قبل يومين
نائبه وزير الدفاع تحدثت عن ارسال قوات
جديده الى هذه المدينه لكن طبعا يعني ربما
مع هذا التصريح للقائد الميداني مديار
المشهور على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
دائما يتحدث عن الاوضاع في المدينه كان
مفاجئا للكثيرين لكن يبقى ان نذكر هنا
بانه يتحدث عن وحده استطلاع متخصصه في
طائرات الدروس الاستكشاف المواقع الروسيه
على محور مخموط وهي التي وجهت لها وفقا
لقوله وفقا لحديثه الاوامر بالانسحاب وفقا
لمصادرنا في المدينه طبعا قال لنا بانه
هناك نوع من الاستماع من جانب الروسيه
وتحديدا طبعا قوات فاجنر في محاوله للتقدم
من قريه خروموفا هم يعني يتركون ربما معظم
الاتجاهات ويحاولون الوصول اليها بغض
النظر عن تمكنهم من السيطره عرضيه على
المناطق التي يتقدمون فيها لماذا ازدهار
لان هذه المدينه او هذه القريه عفوا هي
التي يمر منها الخط الوحيد والطريق الوحيد
الالتفاء في المتبقي للدخول والخروج من
المدينه عبر بلده او مدينه وبالتالي هم
يدركون على ما يبدو ان وصولهم الى هذه
القريه يعني انتهاء الحرب لانهم يدركون
تماما بان القوات الاوكرانيه ستنسحب عندما
تدرك انها ستحاصر داخل المدينه وربما على
الرغم من تصريحات الاوكرانيه بالتمسك
بالمدينه وارسال قوات لكن اذا لاحظنا ايضا
في نفس التصريحات دائما هناك دعني دعيني
اقول خط رجعه لهم على اعتبار انه الرئيس
حتى زيلينسكي كان قد قال باننا لن ندافع
عن مخمود حتى اخر رجل
ايضا المتحدث باسم المنطقه الشرقيه
قبل قال اول امس بانه اذا ما ادركنا ان
تكلفه الحفاظ على الارض ستكون اكبر بكثير
من الحفاظ على ارواح جنودنا فاننا سننسحب
ولكن انسحابنا سيكون منظم ايضا بالنظر الى
تطورات ومجريات الحرب منذ بدايتها ازدهار
ايضا يمكن استخلاص ذلك الاعتبار ان القوات
الاوكرانيه او دعينا نقول
مسيناريو وما جرى فيماريوبل لم يتكرر ابدا
بعد الحرب اقصد هنا ان يصمد او تصمد
القوات الاوكرانيه حتى بعد حصارها وترفض
الخروج من المدينه فقط كان هذا في ماريوبل
لكن في السنيريهات الاخرى وتحديدا ربما في
ليسي شانس لم يكن هذا قد تحقق بل عندما
تدرك القوات الاوكرانيه بانها
ستحاصر تقوم بالانسحاب الى خطوط دفاعيه
تقول بانها تكون هذه الخطوط قد اعدت مسبقا
للحمايه والحفا والحفاظ على ارواح الجنود
الاوكرانيين بالنسبه طبعا لبقيه المحاور
نعم المحور الشمالي هو الاعنف وهو الاقوى
لكن ايضا المعارك مستمره على الشرق وهناك
تقدم كما قالت لنا مصادرنا في الشرق لكن
في الجنوب يبقى الوضع كما هو عليه هناك
نوع من المراوحه في بين في القتال بين
الطرفين تبقى معنا عامر